mother's throughout history have come
forward for the sake of their children
we're coming forth today saying that the
drug war has been more damaging to our
families than the drugs themselves The
Woman's Christian Temperance Union
played a major role in pushing for the
prohibition of alcohol but perhaps less
known are the women's groups such as the
women's organization for national
prohibition reform that were
instrumental in the repeal of the 18th
amendment today the US drug war wreaks
havoc on families which is why mom's
United to end the war on drugs gathered
in front of the Los Angeles Superior
courthouse to deliver a message to
politicians police and moms across the
country we're here sort of in honor of
Mother's Day I became a mother in 1971
for the first time the same year as
Nixon declared the war on drugs so for
me this is very personal as our family
has certainly been badly affected by the
war on drugs as so many other families
have I choose to make our community
safer to bring justice back to the
justice system and to protect all
American liberties by helping to end
this failed drug war we want to
safeguard our children and protect them
from drug dealers and cartels and thugs
but we're not doing it very effectively
through the harsh tactics of enforcement
you don't realize the drug policies in
this country until they have an effect
on you and when you lose a child
your life is never the same nor as the
rest of your family I didn't know better
until it happened to me until I saw my
son going off to California State Prison
twice for nonviolent drug offenses and
the belief that he would get some kind
of rehabilitation in prison I mean
that's a joke my husband and I lost our
only child to not accidental overdose
and in 2008 this thing wasn't attached
to it maybe we do some more research and
find out what does work what will help
them and you know stuck just pointing
the finger and my kid was a lot more
than somebody who use drugs he was in a
wonderful person mothers have typically
been the ones that nurture protect their
children and their family and so mothers
really need to step forward because our
families are and our children are being
arrested are dying in epidemic
proportions because of punitive
prohibitionist policies I think the war
on drugs has to end it hasn't saved
anybody it hasn't changed anything it's
created chaos and neighborhoods and
shootings
it's stupid and our jails are full of
people who have something else to give
to this world other than sitting in jail
for non-violent offense